despite the satisfying way f9 continues
the stories of dom letty and all the
rest there are a number of questions
we've been left to ponder since the
credits rolled here are some of the
biggest
the newest and wildest adventure in the
fast and furious saga is kicked off when
mr nobody sends an encrypted distress
signal meant only for vin diesel's
character dom toretto and his team
in his message he says his plane is
going down with dangerous cargo on board
ramsay is the one who picks it up and
wastes no time in getting most of the
team back together
after some light persuasion she and dom
along with letty roman and tej are on
board
at the crash site however there's no
trace of mr nobody after doing a cursory
sweep for him and coming up empty dom's
crew never seems to spend any more
energy trying to figure out if he's
still alive
sure it looked like a pretty devastating
crash but considering mr nobody's
apparent ability to arrange the
impossible it seems as though nothing is
beyond his grasp
speaking of mr nobody and the impossible
han is apparently alive in f9 despite
the seemingly deadly crash and murder
attempt in tokyo drift
the same scene which we saw revisited
again in fast and furious 6 and furious
7
except the explanation doesn't actually
account for what happened
according to han he was recruited as an
operative by mr nobody
apparently this happened sometime
between the end of fast imperius 6 and
the beginning of tokyo drift which
chronologically takes place between the
6th and 7th films
some time before sean boswell showed up
in tokyo han did a job for mr nobody
that required him to stay hidden
mr nobody then determined the best way
to do this was to fake han's death as no
one would be looking for him
it's a neat workaround for bringing back
the character except for one thing
the car chase han was involved in when
he died was completely impromptu
in tokyo drift we see that han is
fleeing his former business partner
after he got caught stealing
previously it seemed as though deckard
shaw took advantage of that opportunity
to take han out by t-boning him with his
own car
but now we are to understand that mr
nobody somehow staged the entire thing
since we definitely saw that han was
physically present for the entire chase
in tokyo drift
even seeing the crash from inside his
car there's no way he could have somehow
escaped the car before deckard crashed
into him
was mr nobody lurking around ready to
extract him the instant an opportunity
presented itself
if so how did he get han out of the
wrecked car without anyone noticing
f9 gives us some answers but really only
raises more questions
while mr nobody's presence looms large
over the plot of f9 even if he isn't
physically around his protege is nowhere
to be found and isn't even mentioned
introduced and faded the furious little
nobody who's played by scott eastwood
worked alongside the rest of the crew
and thwarting their enemies cipher
little nobody was at the family barbecue
at the end of the film which is
typically a pretty solid indicator that
a character is ascended to the rank of
family and will continue to pop up in
future installments
even still he's completely absent in f9
now
it's not a stretch to say that little
nobody didn't make much of an impression
in fate of the furious
unlike most of the other recurring fast
and furious characters who each have
personality by the bucket full he was by
nature pretty bland and didn't add much
to the crew
granted this was partially because he
was a covert government agent who was
supposed to be able to disappear
but even mr nobody managed to live under
the radar while still being an engaging
character
so perhaps he was left out simply
because he wouldn't be particularly
missed still it's a little odd that with
a plot that so heavily ties into mr
nobody's plans no one would even think
to mention looking for a second in
command
f9 actually does a good job of
explaining why dom and mia have never
mentioned that they had another brother
before and have erased them from all
their childhood stories
it turns out that in the race that
killed dom's father which he told brian
about in the first movie his car had
been tampered with causing it to respond
poorly during the race
teenage dom realized it was his younger
brother jacob who had messed with the
car and assumed he'd sabotaged their
father on purpose
dom banished jacob from the family and
never spoke of him again
however it's later revealed that jacob
stayed with a friend of their dad's name
buddy nearby for about a year before
moving on
this is a little odd seeing that dom or
mia would have possibly crossed paths
with jacob again after he left the
toretto home
after all but he seemed pretty close to
the toretto family
did jacob have to leave the house and
pretend that he wasn't living there if
dom or mia passed by buddy's house
it seems to be the only way they could
have avoided running into one another
and triggering an extremely awkward
conversation
dom says in the film that he knew jacob
was living with buddy so maybe the elder
toretto just avoided buddy for a while
dom soon realizes that the person
responsible for stealing the device
capable of hijacking every super weapon
in the world is his estranged brother
jacob played by john cena
so dom sets off to track down his
long-lost sibling first he visits buddy
and learns jacob has gone to london
then he heads to london where he asks
magdalene shaw which you can find out
there were underworld connections
sure enough she knows right where he can
find jacob and drives him right to his
brother's doorstep but while dom's
detective work is impressive it also
raises some questions
first of all how did he even know where
to find magdalen shaw more importantly
why did he have to do all this tracking
in the first place when he could have
just used the god's eye
first introduced in furious 7 the god's
eye is a piece of tracking software that
can be used to find anyone on the planet
in seconds
the crew used it again and invaded the
furious to track down cipher
plus dom has the inventor of the god's
eye ramsay on his crew
so why the pond hop in when dom could
have cut straight to the chase
did they simply forget they had the
world's most advanced tracking
technology at their disposal
so let's address the elephants in the
room right away there are a lot of
issues with roman nintendo's space plan
[Music]
please tell me that's not a pontiac
fiero strapped to a rocket engine
most of these issues were willing to let
slide because this is a fast and furious
movie and realism has never been a major
selling point for this franchise
however it seems a little odd that after
defying all odds and managing to destroy
the satellite they were sent to disarm
they are then able to essentially
hitchhike home but the astronauts aboard
the international space station without
any negative consequences
granted we don't actually have any clue
what would happen if two men in scuba
suits wound up floating by in a pontiac
bureau outside the international space
station
hardly seems like the sort of thing
anyone would plan for but it does seem
like it should be more severe than just
eating tootsie rolls for a couple of
weeks and then being allowed to tag
along on their trip back to earth
while it's possible roman and tej
escaped on a technicality considering
the possibility that there aren't
actually any laws governing what they
did the same can't be said for everyone
else
dominus crew caused a massive
destruction while working to stop otto
from gaining the power to destroy the
world
this isn't the first time dom's crew has
leveled several city blocks or destroyed
dozens of cars
however in previous films they either
had to go on the run afterward or were
working for the government
which presumably helped clean up the
mess this time they're effectively on
their own
this raises the question of why they're
able to relax at a family barbecue at
the end instead of being arrested for
causing tens of millions of dollars
worth of property damage
not even including all the cars they
destroy they also take out multiple
buildings with their magnetic
shenanigans
it seems a little weird that no one
needs to pay literally for all the
destruction that caused even if it
happened in the name of saving the world
no one needs to know about this once
again just like at the end of fate of
the furious cipher manages to evade
capture at the end of f9
even though the rest of the team she's
working with isn't nearly so lucky
of course sometime between the ending of
fate of the furious and the beginning of
f9 mr nobody somehow managed to track
her down and capture her so we know that
such a thing is possible
but at the same time he didn't manage to
hold on to her for long
plus we have no idea where mr nobody
even is anymore or how to get a hold of
his covert organization
and we definitely expect cipher to be
even more careful this time about
covering her tracks
so it seems like the odds of her being
found before she wants to are low
and that whenever she does reappear it
will be in a fittingly dramatic and
shocking fashion
f9 made an impressive effort to bring
back all sorts of familiar faces from
previous films
even brian was implied to be present at
the final barbecue
although we only got to see his car but
one former member of the team was
noticeably absent
lou cobbs played by dwayne johnson who's
been an integral member of the crew
since fast five
behind the scenes johnson is busy with
his own spin-off franchise hobbs and
shaw as well as numerous other projects
but just because the actor wasn't
available doesn't mean we aren't
wondering where the character
is it seems that given the high stakes
and difficult nature of their mission it
would have made sense to call in the big
guns
but hobbs isn't even mentioned in f9
making us wonder why the characters
wouldn't have thought to call him
perhaps they already knew he wouldn't be
available maybe he's spending more time
with his daughter or visiting his family
in samoa whom he reconnected with and
hobbs and shaw
daddy's staying home
[Laughter]
there are any number of places he could
have been but it feels a little weird
that the movie doesn't even hint
at where he was early in f9 after
surviving several situations that should
have reasonably resulted in his death
roman postulates that perhaps the reason
he keeps defying death is because he and
the rest of the crew
are actually invincible and while tej
and ramsay laugh at roman's outlanders
theory by the end of f9 we're kind of
wondering if he might be on to something
after all letty and han survived crashes
that everyone assumed killed them
roman and tej managed to survive a trip
to outer space in a car that exploded
earlier in the movie
not to mention countless close calls for
every member of the crew throughout the
franchise
of course there is one person who throws
a wrench in this theory giselle who died
at the end of fast and furious 6 saving
han if one member of their crew died it
stands the reason that all of them could
under the right circumstances
unless of course gisele is somehow still
alive too while we're not holding our
breath after getting justice for han we
won't rule anything out
and if gisele ever does return to the
family there really may be something to
roman's bizarre theory
after all check out one of our newest
videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you